do you want to eat some great no the
eyeball is still in I've had faced
before I'm scared I'm grateful brain
tacos I was thinking this is gonna be
way more grotesque oh yeah yes some
citrus rip the trail a shop oh so much
food they taste like um like Mira plays
like tofu I don't know I like that sauce
sure I'll get mad at me but I speckle is
a lingua and then brings the internet
mean like I would totally do that
sauteed brains this looks like brain
this is what they would in artisan
brains crostini oh yeah it's like a
Brooklyn snack oh it's slimy hey yeah
this is good I'm gonna yeah at all yeah
the texture is still in fact it's a
little like soft but damn on this toes
yeah man hell yeah brain fritters
anything fried you're covering and
hiding something clearly oh it's so
squishy what is that you got a rat it's
like a rush hmm this is my favorite one
so far I think yeah it's delicious
no I heard it was like a cherry tomato
but made out of brains brain masala oh
just like grandma used to make yeah you
know yours looks like Kass something no
like I just fed this to my cats last
night this one makes me feel like I'm
gonna have a tummy ache soon no I mean I
get that on all the flavor is good but
it's just like oh my god oh oh that I
don't know it's like scrambled eggs that
used to think things under the condition
of you can't tell me what it is
and just tell me that it's a taco and
I'll eat it and never tell me that it's
a brain ever again
yes final thoughts yes I would Maggie
breathe again yeah I like it yeah I
think I would maybe even have seconds I
wouldn't eat that again
uh-uh would you I think there's some of
those I would that I would definitely
eat again the taco I'm really
and bad